merci catherinettes bureau françoise
mais aujourd'hui c'est le 8e demain ce
sera le 9 fort logiquement est aussi un
anniversaire avec le comité et d'action
laïque
l'ensemble des syndicats et partis de
gauche fêteront 1 au bourget le
centenaire de l'école publique gratuite
obligatoire et laïque
un centenaire que nous résume dominique
laurie si la loi de 1881 de marque les
débuts de la laïcité
l'idée d'une école publique ouverte à
tous remonte à la révolution en 1792 le
député condorcet fait approuver par la
convention son rapport sur l'instruction
publique qui réclame déjà la gratuité de
l'enseignement près d'un siècle plus
tard après la victoire des républicains
en 1876 jules ferry ministre de
l'instruction publique
promulguée le 28 mars 82 les lois
instituant l'obligation scolaire pour
tous les enfants de 7 à 13 ans le choix
de la laïcité faire 82 c'est un choix de
société
si à un moment où la formule convient
c'est celui là il s'agit de savoir si on
repose sur une société d'ancien régime
avec des notables presque de droit divin
qui en tout cas par leur naissance ont
un droit naturel à commander ou si on
choisit ses chefs et c'est apparemment
très loin de la laïcité est en fait
c'est ça l'enjeu de la laïcité
cette école que ses adversaires appelle
l'école sans dieu déchaîne les passions
elle est violemment combattue et
condamné par l'épiscopat jusqu'en 1902
les écoles confessionnelles font
concurrence à l'école publique
deux ans plus tard émile combes
président du conseil interdit aux
congrégations religieuses
le droit d'enseigner la querelle
scolaire se déchaîne et divise le pays
végétant plus ou moins des écoles libres
continue d'exister mais le 3 septembre
40 le régime de vichy abroge
l'interdiction d'enseigner faite aux
congrégations
en 1941 il accorde des subventions aux
écoles catholiques
c'est la revanche de toutes les droites
et c'est la revanche
aussi d'un certain nombre de catholiques
qui n'avaient pas accepté les lois
laïques
c'est aussi une situation d'urgence car
les écoles privées ont beaucoup de
difficulté à vivre mais la mesure
symbolique c'est la suppression de la
loi de 1981 que les congrégations
désormais sont légitimes et du jour au
lendemain dans les écoles des frères des
écoles chrétiennes reparaissent les
soutanes qui avait disparu à la
libération les subventions à l'école
privée sont supprimés la querelle
scolaire reprend de plus belle en 1951
le vote des lois marié baranger
rétablisse une aide au secteur privé
mais c'est surtout la loi debré en 1959
qui redonne son souffle aux écoles
libres enfin en 1977 la loi guermeur
garanties aux établissements privés le
respect de leur caractère propre
pendant ces années les partisans de les
collègues se sont sans cesse élevé
contre l'attribution de fonds publics
aux écoles privées
en 1980 la victoire de françois
mitterrand c'est aussi le triomphe des
militants de la laïcité car dans les 110
propositions socialistes figurent en
bonne place la création d'un grand
service public et laïque d'éducation